welcome to the first democratic debate
of democrats polling well enough to be
in the presidential debates one is
clearly different congresswoman Tulsi
Gabbard where is the conversation about
peace Gabbard served in Iraq and now she
pushes for ending wars
every time we launched these
interventionist regime change wars every
single one of us pays the price we have
to honor our servicemen and women by
only sending them on missions that are
worthy of their sacrifice there seldom
is a discussion that I've heard about
what is our mission exactly that's
exactly the problem what is the clear
achievable goal so in Afghanistan you
would have gotten out when go in defeat
al-qaeda get out Gabbard also says we
should talk with our enemies he met with
Syria's dictator and was criticized for
that you need to acknowledge that bashar
al-assad is a murderous despot i would
think that they would say we should talk
to everybody better talk than wage war
you would think that's what they would
say so what's going on with your party
democrats used to be the anti-war party
they're heavily influenced by foreign
policy establishment in Washington whose
whole power base is built around
continuing this status quo so much so to
the point where when I'm calling for an
end to these wasteful wars they're
saying well gosh Tulsi why are you such
an isolationist as though the only way
that we can relate with other countries
in the world is by bombing them or
putting crippling economic sanctions in
place Gabbard would also end another war
[Applause]
he'd start by legalizing marijuana I've
never smoked marijuana I never will I've
never drank alcohol I've chosen not to
in my life
this is about free choice and if
somebody wants to do that our country
should not be making a criminal out of
them so once for an adult we own our own
bodies and we ought to be able to poison
them we want yes what you haven't
proposed legalizing heroin or cocaine I
think that's the direction that we need
to take while still criminalized
those who are traffickers and dealers of
these drugs isn't that hypocritical you
can use it but nobody can sell it to you
yeah no it's not at all I think there's
a difference here where you have those
who are profiting off of selling
substances that are harmful to others as
opposed to those who are making those
choices on their own to do what they
wish with their bodies senator Harris
says she's proud of her record at one
debate she criticized Kamala Harris for
being so eager to jail people she put
over 1500 people in jail for marijuana
violations and then laughed about it
when she was asked if she ever smoked
marijuana that moment changed the race
she was leading in the bedding
immediately she fills seven points ten
days later another seven points
you killed her off I'm for the people
man
I was speaking the truth and and and
speaking for a lot of people good for
Gabbard for bringing that up
and for running an ad that at least
mentions America's debt our national
debt is something that we all need to
take seriously but like most Democrats
Gabbard would spend billions on
expensive new programs I support
Medicare for all and I want to tell you
why Medicare for all we can't afford
this stuff a military entire budget is
seven hundred billion Bernie Sanders
admits it will cost three trillion
dollars the money that we are going to
save by ending these wasteful wars
you're right it won't cover every other
thing that we need to accomplish for
example free college don't you think
college has already waste a lot of money
they do absolutely and why is it costing
more and more and more every single year
just throwing whatever it'll cost wait
it's free well this is the problem is
just throwing more money at it isn't
going to solve it so we have to deal
with the systemic problem here the root
cause of the problem one of which is how
much administrators of a lot of these
colleges are being paid or overpaid
let's actually see where these dollars
are going let's look at the fact that
these universities many of them don't
have any kind of accountability or
transparency in well you have it if you
make it free if the student had some
skin in the game his own money
oh my care
about how many administrators there are
but what we're working on it and we'll
be releasing this in detail in the
course of our campaign while we wait for
that Gabbard points out that her own
education costs much less we had an
education
tent in our cabin I did classes in that
tent online you know mortar attacks were
coming in I'd have to run out and go
into the bunker but I tested out of
probably somewhere between forty and
sixty credits cheaper a lot cheaper
Gabbard also joins other Democrats and
demanding that government decide what
businesses must pay people a $15 minimum
wage yeah how does that not destroy
opportunity for a 17 year old in his
first job who isn't worth $15 an hour
we're looking at this as an investment
in people you've never run a business
you've never had to deal with hiring
workers and having to pay minimum wage
well let me let me stop you right there
because my parents started a restaurant
and all five of us kids you know it took
turns sweeping floors wiping tables and
serving food and and experienced the
challenges and the hardships and also
the rewards of a family-run business I
apologize for not knowing you at all
right family restaurant I'm glad we can
have a civil argument about some of
these areas where we disagree a few
politicians want to do that anymore
isn't it of all the people pulling over
a percent you're the only one who so far
has come and sat down to talk our
leaders are increasingly unwilling to
sit down with those who may be
quote-unquote on the other team I love
my country you love our country let's
come together as Americans with
appreciation for our Constitution our
freedoms civil liberties and rights and
have this civil discourse and dialogue
about how we can move forward together
that would be good thank you very much
thank you that's just a fraction of our
45 minute discussion we'll post the full
interview later this week